In doing all of my like deep dive and research
on your book, and I read the People Magazine article,
and I was just reading everything I could
to sort of get a sense of where things were at.
I can't help it, I did get a little bit obsessed
with all the cute boys that you've known and dated.
Well.
And got engaged to.
What can I say? Ah.
(Drew laughs loudly)
Oh, it's true.
(Jennifer laughs)
Is it true that Johnny Depp asked you to marry him
after dating for a few weeks?
It's worse than that.
Wait, what? Tell me everything!
(audience laughs)
I was engaged to Matthew Broderick
and Johnny Depp in the same month.
(audience cheers and applauds)
But that's so.
(Drew and Jennifer scream)
Like the two it boys.
Yeah, it was really a sign
that there was trouble afoot on my part.
I mean, honestly, I just thought it was God rescuing me
from one bad situation,
and just lovingly plopping me into a Johnny Depp souffle.
That's what I thought.
You have to understand Johnny Depp,
1989 Johnny Depp, so beautiful.
Yeah.
So you've never seen a more beautiful, whoa.
You have to read the description in the book.
It's quite, it's almost inhuman.
I will say I'm very happy that like,
you look so hot and sexy, you're right.
I mean, wait, talk more about that.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, you do.
I get it.
(Jennifer exclaims)
You've always had the most incredible figure.
I will never forget watching you
in "Dirty Dancing,"
What do you mean?
and like the thing on the railing,
and you're doing, you know, your dance,
and you have the most beautiful body,
and you are the most beautiful woman,
and you were so captivating, and I was so in love with you.
You know, Jimmy Fallon and I actually reenacted
I know.
something in honor of you.
Okay, you know how many people have attempted that.
It's so famous.
That is my favorite attempt.
Really?
100%. Do you know why?
Why?
Because you have joy,
even though he's sticking his feet into your ribcage.
Yes.
And it feels horrible,
and you sold it, and it was funny, and sweet.
Oh I'm so relieved.
Aren't you so happy with it?
Yes.
Well, to get our seal of approval is huge.
Did you feel good?
It's such a famous iconic,
I mean it literally is in so many.
Didn't you enjoy it?
I really did.
Jimmy felt like it was best on his back because I,
I don't know how, how did you guys do that?
Okay, you know.
It's so scary.
I did not do it 'til the day we shot it.
Seriously?
Oh no, I feel like it must have been making the producers,
and Patrick, and the director, everyone insane
because I refused, was too scared, I refused,
and I basically just couldn't do it.
I couldn't make myself until the day
when all the people were watching and then I had to do it.
And you did it and it's perfect, it's perfect.
(audience cheers and applauds)
It came out good.
I really do love how you cross your feet.
Yeah, that's, it's such beautiful form.
Well, you know, all those ballet classes as a kid,
you know, paid off like that.
And I know there's sort of been history
with you and Patrick Swayze.
You know, you talk about it in the book,
and you discuss sort of the disconnect,
sometimes lack of chemistry, lack of trust,
trying to kind of figure it out with each other.
But Johnny and Baby are the ultimate couple.
There is so much chemistry.
Yeah, I mean, chemistry is very different.
The body has a different story than the mind, right?
So my body and his body really liked each other.
There's an energy where it doesn't make sense in life,
but it makes sense between the sheets.
Has anyone else ever had that?
(audience laughs lightly)
Is that, am I the only one? Okay, I'm weird.
No, no, no, I, well I'm just thinking
of some of the people I slept with
that just don't make sense at all,
that was where my head went.
Exactly, exactly.
Exactly, but.
Why? Why?
Exactly.
All right.
So is it true that there is going
to be a "Dirty Dancing" sequel?
Yes.
(Drew screams in excitement)
(audience cheers and applauds)
And is it true that Baby is back at Kellerman's?
Yes.
No!
We all need this in the world.
And is it true there will be dancing?
Yes.
Yes!
Will there be music, sex?
By the way.
Oh, here's a question.
Who do you think
Would be the guy?
Should be the next inappropriate match for Baby?
Oh God. Um, huh.
How about Sh-merry Sh-miles?
Who?
Somebody who rhymes with Sh-merry Sh-miles.
Sh-merry Sh-miles.
Harry Styles!
Yes, thank you, yes.
(audience applauds)
You're right, Harry Styles, done.
(upbeat music)